the Federal Reserve's rates guidance and
its ongoing holdings of securities will
ensure that monetary policy remains
highly accommodative consistent with an
aggressive pursuit of our mandated
objectives of maximum employment and
price stability asset purchases are not
on a preset course the committee's
decisions about their pace will remain
contingent on the economic outlook and
on the committee's ongoing assessment of
the likely efficacy and costs of the
program committee participants generally
believe that because the headwinds to
recovery will debate only gradually
achieving and maintaining maximum
employment and price stability will
require a patient policy approach that
involves keeping the target for the
federal funds rate below its longer-run
normal value for some time it's less
surprising the market or easing policy
as it is avoiding a tightening until we
can be comfortable that the economy is
in fact growing you know the way we want
it to be growing so this was a step I
would it was a step of precautionary
step if you will